on continue si vous le voulez bien à
part les deux des mesures annoncées par
le premier ministre on pourra pas être
aussi parce que le temps nous manquerait
mais il ya eu aussi une prise de
position assez forte sur le droit
d'asile et ses excès pour edouard
philippe
il y à des abus qui ne peuvent pas
continuer le droit d'asile est un trésor
nous y consacrons des moyens en forte
hausse c'est le prix de la fidélité à
nos valeurs
mais c'est aussi pour cette raison que
nous devons lutter avec fermeté contre
les abus nous continuerons nous
continuerons évidemment à offrir aux
demandeurs d'asile des conditions
d'accueil et de protection sociale
conforme à nos principes mais nous
devons nous assurer que les demandeurs
d'asile choisissent la france pour ses
valeurs pour son histoire pour sa langue
pour ce qu'elle est et non parce que
notre système serait plus favorable que
celui mis en place dans un pays voisin
dans un pays européen
alors ça c'est assez c'est assez nouveau
un dead d'une expression aussi explicite
de ce qui serait une forme d' effet
d'aubaine pour les demandeurs d'asile
d'effet d'aubaine dans le choix de la
france pour une législation qui serait
plus favorable
ce qui est certain en tout cas et le
figaro le révélait ce matin avec des
chiffres inédits c'est que les
et demandent le droit d'asile augmente
de façon forte parfois regardez ce
graphique depuis le début d'année les
demandes en provenance de la géorgie ont
augmenté de 87 % + 32 % pour les
demandeurs d'asile albanais et puis vous
découvrez les autres chiffres en même
temps et puis l'autre partie du problème
on pose tout sur la table avant
d'engager le débat c'est que une fois
que c'est le mandant d'asile sont en
france même lorsqu on leur refuse
eh bien ils ne repartent pas écouter ce
commentaire de jean marc leclerc c'est
notre spécialiste des questions de
police et de sécurité au figaro la
politique doit copier des illégaux en
fait est un véritable fiasco en france
seul un migrant en situation illégale
sur dix est effectivement reconduits
donc c'est pas satisfaisant le souci
c'est que on privilégie actuellement des
solutions comme l'aide au retour
dans un rapport parlementaire par
exemple tout récent et c'est un message
un peu ambivalent envoyé au pays source
qui consiste à dire si vous nous envoyez
des migrants ils toucheront de l'argent
stéphane marchand ont publié les
statistiques ce matin de demande d'asile
en france qui augmente alors même que
dans le reste de l'europe elle ans plus
tôt en france a diminué
d'où cette idée qui a peut-être une
espèce de d'effet d'aubaine et qu'il
faut corriger ça
la france est un pays dont le système
social est particulièrement favorable
donc il est naturel que les gens
viennent chercher de l'asile en france
s'ils ont le choix entre plusieurs pays
mais j'ai l'impression quand on parle de
tout ça que c'est le petit côté de la
lorgnette les différences de revenus les
quand on voit la démographie africaine
qui va passer en 2050 à plusieurs
milliards d'habitants
si la différence de revenu reste la même
entre nous et eux ce que nous vivons
actuellement c'est une à tout petit
apéritif de ce qu'il va se passer
donc il faut entièrement revoir toutes
les relations internationales et
notamment les coopérations et c'est
plutôt que d'ergoter sur pour savoir
s'il ya 12 % de plus de- albanais qui
sont arrivés
le problème n'est pas là le problème
c'est que 30%
si ça continue si ça continue ça va être
500%
donc c'est ça la réalité à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés c'est cette réalité
qu'il faut traiter et il faut la traiter
par des moyens qui n'ont rien à voir
avec ceux de dd des services français
qui traite et qui fournit ces
statistiques il ya eu 300 mails déboutés
du droit d'asile depuis la crise
migratoire de 2015
est-ce que renaud girard sur ce sujet là
edouard philippe parle comme donald
trump ou comme comme salvini où on en
est loin encore non non elle est loin
parce que ce qu'il ne dit pas c'est que
ces statistiques l'albanie la georgie
depuis que des biens sont des pays qui
vivent en paix ils sont simplement moins
développé que la france est
effectivement les aides sociales sont
beaucoup moins généreuse mais l albanais
vous pouvez travailler vous pouvez faire
des cultures il ya un premier ministre
que je connais que deux démocrates
et vous pouvez vous baigner dans la mer
méditerranée mais évidemment c'est plus
intéressant d'aller en france où le
système d'assurance sociale et le plus
généreux d'europe
il est tout à fait évident et il suffit
suffit de lire les enquêtes qui ont été
faites sur dans les communautés
immigrées que
par exemple ceux qui viennent de du sri
lanka et ses îles et c'est comme ça
comme un marché si vous voulez qu'elle
est le pays le plus intéressant il
s'intéresse particulièrement à la france
en tant que culture française alors le
droit d'asile
ce que n'a pas dit le premier ministre
et que le droit d'asile
en fait ça fait partie d'une valeur
fondamentale est une valeur fondamentale
de la république française des sons des
dès sa naissance
parce que c'était accueillir sur le sol
français
les autres européens qui étaient
favorables à l'idée républicaine et qui
étaient persécutés par les monarques qui
avait n'est ce pas qui c'était ça l'idée
c'est en fait la ville c'est pour les
gens qui soutenaient n'est ce pas les
valeurs françaises et notamment par
exemple des valeurs d'égalité entre
entre la femme et l'homme et je ne suis
pas du tout sûr que les maliens qui ont
demandé l'asile là qu'on a vu dans dans
les statistiques
il considère qu' une femme doivent avoir
les mêmes droits qu'un homme est donc ce
sont des gens qui en fait ne partagent
pas nos valeurs et c'est un détournement
bien sûr à ce mentaliser par les réseaux
de passeurs c'est un détournement massif
du droit d'asile
je suis pas sûr que là dessus
le premier ministre est été suffisamment
clair je pense que il
il y a si vous voulez l'europe est
soumise à un mouvement à des trafics des
trafics d'êtres humains considérables
c'est une
c'est un trafic c'est une activité
illégale qui rapporte beaucoup plus
d'argent aujourd'hui en afrique que la
drôme il faut bien le voir et nous ne
savons pas encore le
nous ne savons pas arrêter ce phénomène
alors par ailleurs il faut souligner et
stéphane le disait très bien qu' il ya
une explosion démographique en afrique
et donc il faut voir comment ces
africains vont avoir de plus en plus
envie d'aller en france à dire vous
remarquez que c'est des pays assez riche
ou en paix parce qu'on veut on veut
mieux en fait la guinée c'est un pays en
paix tu un pays deux présidents présents
s'appelle alpha condé qui étaient
déconseillés par kouchner par sarkozy et
ses amis et évidemment ils veulent aller
mieux mais nous n'avons pas les moyens
de leur donner du travail ou des
logements parce que nous avons déjà pas
les moyens de donner du travail à la
population française qui est sur le sol
français
alors je pense qu'il faut une
immigration il faut une immigration
parce qu'on n'atteindra jamais
limitation mais fournit une immigration
choisie est pas une immigration subie et
il faut aussi je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec stéphane il faut prendre
très réellement et voir ce qu'on peut
faire mais fait une conférence
internationale et les américains sont
tout à fait insensible à ça les chinois
aussi également est ce les européens
s'inquiètent de ce phénomène des déesses
qu'on fait face à l'explosion des mots
commerce de la michel renaud girard
voici le point de vue de nos internautes
ils sont 76% à considérer qu'il faut de
nouvelles règles du droit d'asile en
france et de commentaires celui de
babineau qui dit que la priorité c'est
d'un meilleur accompagnement des
demandeurs d'asile et autres migrants
tandis que nicole estime que l'asile ne
devrait être accordée qu'à ceux qui
vivent dans des pays en guerre
et je voudrais faire réagir d'orge et
kuzmanovic éclair chartier à cette
proposition de jordan bardella vous
savez qui était la tête de liste du
ration nationale pour les européennes et
qui dit deux choses qui demandent deux
choses 1 que les demandes d'asile soit
examinée depuis les pays d'origine c'est
à dire avant même l'entrée sur le
territoire français et que deuxièmement
les demandes provenant de pays qui ne
sont pas en guerre soit automatiquement
rejetée ce sont des mesures de bon sens
dans le jeu kuzmanovic non enfin il on
parle de choses tout à fait différentes
on mélange les l'asile
politique imaginons un cas extrême pour
la première proposition de monsieur
bardella on est la deuxième guerre
mondiale vous avez juste juifs qui sont
poursuivis ils font leur demande depuis
l'allemagne
si stupide les gens fuient ils font leur
demande là où ils arrivent ils se
cachent
enfin quand les gens sont vraiment en
guerre et d'ailleurs on ne respecte pas
tellement les accords internationaux
parce que je suis d'accord que monsieur
gérard c c'est ce sont les valeurs de la
république que d'accueillir les gens et
les dix propositions mais que les que
pour les pays non en guerre ne dit
cependant le corse l'exemple mauvais
parce que les allemands nazis autoriser
les gifles demander asile mais c'est le
problème c'est que c'est les pays
notamment les états unis d'amérique
une conférence à lausanne à l'été 1958
qui ont refusé d'accorder les jets les
visas est juste les conventions en 1951
à genève parce qu'on a signé des accords
internationaux sur la protection des
réfugiés de guerre il ya une obligation
à laquelle ans contrevient c'est
l'obligation de non refoulement
or l'organisme au niveau européen en
ayant passé des accords avec la turquie
à qui on a encore donné en juin 2010 8 6
milliards pour faire ce qu'ils veulent
avec ces gens qui ont fui pour le coup
une guerre en syrie ce qui leur permet
de faire des provocations à la grèce
régulièrement en ce moment où est ce
qu'ils valent terme mais leur avion
fonds touche pipi avec les bateaux grecs
et il frôle les îles grecques en
permanence mais on a on a un problème
global c'est que
monsieur edouard philippe le premier
ministre a parlé d'harmonisation du
droit d'asile au niveau européen cc il
ne ressortent à chaque fois au dernier
conseil européen ils n'ont même pas
réussi à se mettre d'accord
l'italie et la hongrie bloc l'allemagne
et la france parlent d'harmonisation
sans réellement pour proposer quoi que
ce soit et visiblement monsieur le
premier ministre ne connaît pas les
accords de schengen sis du même nom oui
mais on a un grave problème c'est quand
l'allemagne décide en 2015 est important
en 2015 d'accueillir un million de
personnes est régulièrement donc pas au
bout de cinq ans ils sont ils ont un
passeport schengen peuvent aller où ils
veulent conséquence la pause chartier
dernière chose et c'est long et c'est la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
elles nous imposent parce que notre
spécialiste au blé dire c'est que depuis
2007 la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme
oui nous pèse sur une souveraineté et
oblige à un recours même quand il ya
refus donc de la part de froid tant
qu'on ne peut rien faire qu'un chantier
pour corriger les excès revenir sur ces
chiffres effectivement je pense que ça
renvoie à ce qu'on appelle le tourisme
migratoires et il est dû au fait que les
règlements dublin n'est pas tout à fait
appliquer puisque le règlement de dublin
suppose que le pays par lequel rentre le
migrant dans l'union européenne et celui
qui examine la demande d'asile en fait
et c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs l'italie
s'est beaucoup plaint de recevoir des
tas de gens mais il y en a beaucoup en
fait les pays n'examine pas le premier
pays d'arrivée n'examine pas cette
demande ce qui permet ensuite en effet
une espèce de tourisme entre guillemets
migratoire donc ça à mon avis ça fait
référence à ce point à ce point là
ensuite en effet l'idée qu' il faille
finalement réglementé ça se mettre
d'accord au niveau européen pour faire
face à ce phénomène me semble quand même
assez logique même si ça suppose des de
résoudre d'énormes difficultés
il ya quand même des pistes qui seront
avancées mais je ne vois pas par
ailleurs vers d'autres solutions que
celle là c'est à dire que je ne vois pas
des pays se claquemurer parce que c'est
impossible de se claquemurer face à ces
flux sont les rois en mettant des
embêtements des fonds oui à un moment il
faut quand même en ils vont quand même
je pense avoir quelques petits soucis
avec le nom européenne parce que c'est
facile de claques murray ses frontières
et en même temps de recevoir les fonds
de l'union européenne donc là il ya
quand même
mais même la faillite et courges et peu
plus voilà vous avez devant vous savez
je considérerais une autre règle de
poste je pense qu'on reviendra sur ce
sujet